hi welcome to games of the week this
week we have a lot of stuff going on we
have that are still happening
women will serve in suits going on still
and well everything is going pretty
equal in women roles championship the
match between Jew in June and Cory
Aquino day moved that match so they did
the first six games in China and then
they moved it to Russia because they
wanted to have the hometowns both
players honours which i think is pretty
cool but since we don't really have an
imbalance in that tournaments I decided
to go with the more juicy tournament
title still and today well before today
I was planning on showing the game
against Leslie so and furious job but
well since here is just a bit giri that
kind of became the game of today and so
we're gonna look at that and hopefully
we have enough time to cover another one
as well I I mean I don't really know
Firoz job personally I remember him as a
big kid
he was always super nice and um I'm very
glad that he's becoming this very
talented young super Grandmaster and
yeah
he lives and I want to say France now
yeah and he plays for freedom what I
also did for about two weeks and yeah so
he today played against a nice Gary Tata
still is happening in Netherlands
industries the Dutch number one man so
that was definitely interesting so
fierce rose white and it she's black so
they started the game with the 45 c4 e6
Knight c3 Bishop e7 exchange here Bishop
for c6 pretty common theory nothing
crazy or novelty just yet for those of
you who are interested the name of this
opening is Queen gambit declined
Sammy's love but 9 f6 is common to have
been played but well not yet some people
call it the Marshall gambits and some of
these exchange lines are without tonight
at six well 96 was played now so the
first question is even though this is a
very well-known opening some of us might
not play it as whites and we might never
actually face this opening in our game
so I think it's important to know how
you want to develop your pieces as white
and as black so usually in this type of
setups what do you think white wants her
pieces to go where do you think this
Bishop belongs this night belongs same
for black where do you think this Knight
and Bishop belong take a little bit of
time and think about that because
understanding where your pieces belong
helps you get a good harmony
your future moves and yeah so this
Bishop seems to really belong in d3 so
III you as lies III should be the first
move you think about and after that the
only thing is if you want to play III
you have to be mindful of your taking
away your bishops route back so you have
to consider what if Knight h5 and even
denied h5 we know we've heard from our
beginner times that new students move to
pieces one piece twice in the opening so
95 would be moving one piece twice but I
feel like right now we could make an
exception because well you're trying to
take away this Bishop well if I was
black I think if I didn't know the
theory I wouldn't have done it and I
would go with the more simple approach
trying to play something like short
castle and then I would try and fight to
have my bishop in this diagonal with
something like Bishop g4 be savage 556
that's that's a very common maneuver but
hmm well if a nice grey play is not h5i
not gonna really tell us a bad move but
so as white what do you think you should
do
well yeah but what if one up Bishop e5
well the thing is wax never gonna will
ask the thing f6 is not a very good move
because the problem is when you play f6
your whole harmonii kind of well you
don't really have an harmony anymore and
even after Bishop g3 this is white
already looks better there are some
weaknesses that white can try to go
after just to put it simply it will make
your life harder as black so if you are
gonna attack this Bishop here you might
as well go after it it's something like
97 and then Bishop g3 you could consider
Bishop g3 but the thing is do you really
want to move the bishop again or would
you rather something like that yeah what
do you think like this pawn would be
more useful on e5
yeah but if your pond is here you the
center is kind of moving and black could
consider trying to push d4 and opening
center to Bishop's liking open center
those stuff so would you still want to
go forward with the pond being on e5
I mean allowing 95 dvx back
so what do you think what do you think
is the blacks corns biggest weakness
mm-hmm yeah so try to exploit that g4
doesn't work tactically because if g4
Knight takes e5 d takes e5 and the g4
pawn Falls yeah precisely so you have
the right idea to attack tonight but
instead of playing something like g4
exactly now you're playing like a 2700
yeah Bishop e2 is a good move and
furious trap played it's in his game so
after Bishop b2 Knight takes e5 d takes
e5 g6 is pretty much the only move
should not lose the night and you're
gonna you're gonna take this and see
White's position already just feels more
comfortable even though there might not
be an advantage in love it's this
position could probably be equal just
more chances for white and it's more
just more comfortable that's how I would
describe it and you have a clear clear
weakness to go after this h5 on so
theorists replayed 92 which was indeed a
novelty previously some people for
example I think alexandroff against
Ramanath played something like route d1
I've which allowed f6 take and take back
and the game ended in a draw day this
was in 2012 and but in this game well
today night e 2 was played which indeed
was a novelty the same ideas of f6
followed but after take take proxy 1
because the easiest way to think about
this room district belongs to d1 you
like the rockin c1 isn't really doing
anything and this rook should be on d1
that's usually how you can try to
eliminate moves such as like rook c1 or
Knight f4 because you don't really know
where your knife belongs just yet but
you know where your look rook belongs so
that's why you try to do something like
that and here do you think castel's are
still good idea or that ship a sale
that's a good that's a good reaction it
is
well surprisingly black did play
Castille so and so did white like
nothing's happening it's just a normal
opening everything is good and well
obviously after castel's there should be
a move like honking a chase because just
I want to call it common sense and now
try and take a little bit of time and
think about what whites should do
so what are your candidate moves
okay
okay so you want to do something in the
center pretty much yeah makes sense
right mmm so do you think efore works
so what is the well pretty much only
move for blacks to do after efore yeah
so how would you proceed with d4 because
your knight doesn't really have a good
place to go at least at the moment you
could try to bring it to c5 but yeah I'm
not sure if this is a practical idea I
mean it looks nice but the way they went
about it in the game was with Knight f4
and in this situation move b6 seems
quite intriguing because well first of
all that I deal with 94-95 the c5 square
is covered at least there's that
and you see like I move such as c5 even
though it might never happen because of
the weakness and the outpost of d5 oops
not yet it's still you're like
supporting the idea and now it's I feel
like it would be a good fighting between
I mean compared to what happened in the
game I feel like the Mystics might have
been a better fight but I can see why it
wouldn't be the first choice to try and
play something like b6 because well
logically b6 is going to try and play c5
either with pawn or at least take away
the square and it also creates this c6
weakness immediately so I don't think I
would be six as black at least in this
specific situation I don't think I would
and surprisingly
they manage didn't either so in the game
here we played Bishop e5 so this book is
also very nice for whites who do you
take another little time to figure out
what to do
9:35 doesn't work right Knight takes h5
doesn't work right okay yeah it's very
at least there could also be Bishop
which - King H - Queen ashore there
could also be Bishop g4 it's it should
it just shouldn't work so when you'd
realize that night is five doesn't work
you also you gotta move the night so
where do you want to take it yeah 92
it's well I mean it's not a blunder but
also it's not a good move the whole idea
behind playing Knights in this position
you play Knight f4 to come to d3 given
the chance yeah and I feel like another
way to think about it is me six wouldn't
you can't play Knight e3 anymore at
least immediately so maybe that's why b6
would have been a slightly better move
yeah exactly so Bishop e5 did give this
idea of night d3 a real chance and after
Knight d3 well black retrieved the
bishop back to g7 because well
theoretically you could think about
something like trying to make a battery
on h2 but it shouldn't work least of all
there is going to be an f4 and well
Bishop g7 protecting the King sorry I
think it's a more logical approach sorry
so you want to play Queen is for first
there's always take back mm-hmm
I feel like oh yeah also White's pieces
are more ready and also black has clear
weaknesses whereas white doesn't really
it would take black awhile to create
that clear weakness to attack so whites
would have an easier game it's not a
blunder it works I'm just eyeballing it
but wise would have an easier game so
Bishop g7 this night has to come to eat
you I mean you could try a four but same
reasons again your Knights wouldn't
really be doing much in c5 also in e2
you always have the chance to cover up
the King if necessary so there is this
idea with 93 coming up most likely and
so black tries h4 to take away the idea
logically also black could be creating
threats to want to play something like
h3 and creates that clear weakness
because black has these two bishops but
black doesn't really have anything to
attack to with the bishop so that's why
I Blackwood hoped for trying to open up
something to do some h3 and then try to
bring the bishop to white squared Bishop
out so logically white I would block
this idea of h3
here black plates clean east seven I
feel like it's just trying to bring out
the pieces rather than having like super
clear path now this is actually I think
it's a pretty cool move so what do you
think why it should do
that's
also be mindful that's your pawn is on
dresser
you're thinking about it's very
correctly yes so in order to just give
you some ideas of how you can make that
decision so usually when you reach a
position when you don't see like you
have more than one moves that you have
to start calculating about it helps a
lot if you actually make a list which
well in your mind or so-called candidate
moves so the idea is that you make this
candidate moves how many they are could
be two could be five whatever you make
till you like think about so these are
my good moves that I'm gonna start
calculating and then you like organize
them by importance so this should this
is hopefully this is something that
becomes like a pattern that you do
automatically without having to actually
ask yourself these questions
but in order for it to become like
subconscious thing you have to ask
yourself questions for a while so the
easiest way is to think about so first
of all as soon as your opponent makes a
move what does my opponent want your
opponent's wants your pawn to put it
simply and then to come up with a
response but against for that opponents
move the first things to be mindful to
our checks and takes so do you have any
logical viable checks takes yeah exactly
but you still have to be mindful of it
so if like if you see a take like even
though 94 doesn't work it's important
that you like keep an eye on it so you
know that this d4 pawn is under attack
because something that happens a lot
with beginners and intermediate students
is that they forget that they're
attacking something or that their
opponent is it
something so if you every move you try
and ask yourself this question that what
can you take you're always gonna
remember what you're attacking yet and
you are attacking d4 so ting now that
you know you're attacking d4 you see
that your opponent is defending it and
you don't have any viable it checks or
takes or now you come up with moves with
threats so now you're asking yourself
what can I do to create a threat and
this if you can wipe this pawn off the
board you have an easier game so how can
you do that it and then you come to the
DCE five hits all of your targets you're
saving your pawn at least temporarily
you're attacking this d4 pawn and if
take I feel like even something as clear
as even taking withdrew or even taking
with Knight this should be good enough
advantage because least of all the
whites who try and attack this pawn and
the blacks King is pretty weak just
looking at it
might be a little hard to organize a
clear attack and you might not see clear
win but you see clear advantage here so
it's important for black to keep this
Bishop as a defender but if you want to
keep the bishop means you you have to
defend the pawn and that's what Gary did
in game rooty 8 depending upon what's
the natural move you're thinking but
what is your opponent once yes what is
something that it's even cleared and
more clear than that even more clear
than this
check stakes yeah so that's what your
opponent wants so if your opponent wants
to take on e5 how can you protect it yep
so if you start asking yourself these
questions you once like blundered upon
and also f4 takes away the idea of Queen
g5 so then if black lets you have like
two moves in a row
your next move to start thinking about
is f5 f6 so that's why black kinda has
to play Bishop a5 that's the most
logical way to approach and now this
game becomes so why it has advantage
even if it's not a clear advantage White
has a better position more comfortable
game more treads black has more
weaknesses and so the best way to think
about it is now it's the time to regroup
is your Knights doing anything useful in
e2 not really so where would it be more
useful you want this light whoa yes I
agree with that but not really gonna
happen anytime soon yeah so this night
it would be more useful here right on f3
list of all the way to do that simply
King edge to your ideas to do this this
you're you're putting more pressure on
h4 d4
after king h2 also after king ish - you
are avoiding any kind of like weird
takes that could potentially come up
black plays Queen e6 Knight g1 Bishop h6
putting more pressure here Knight f3 so
the thing is after Knight f3 Bishop d3
does it work
Wow
oh we're before now well the thing is
whatever this Queen g5 comes up there's
always gonna be the F for response and I
think again probably could play King
edge to that H 3 would be defended why
it has a very easy response to these
kind of attacks so in the game they went
about it with group d8 now f4 and trying
to regroup Bishop d3 mmm does it work
does it not work
or let me ask you this what about bishop
effort does this work
you are thinking about it correctly but
you don't need to capture it
mmm you don't need to capture the rook
you can just capture the knight back yes
yeah Bishop back yeah but so yeah
Bishop before doesn't work because the
Queen is under attack first of all now
those Bishop d3 work well that's the
thing is I don't think it's about
winning the pie it's about is your king
safe enough
because okay least of all we could take
on d3 I think and you can't place like
we should be fast because of rookie one
and my next move I'm I want to try and
play maybe 90 ch4 maybe 94 this truck is
ready to double up yeah I feel like why
it has a more dynamic advantage even
though could be giving up upon so that's
why Bishop d3 yeah yeah Bishop d3 is um
shouldn't work and unless there's some
crazy hectic involves but it shouldn't
work so in the game black played Queen
e7 so the main idea is to protect this
guy and also maybe we shall before now
because Knight f4 doesn't work anymore
not attacking anything so in this
situation future actually went Forex
Queen exchange even though black King
seems to be weak there is no clear way
for y to try to attack it and if the
Queen's are off the board and mmm in
this pawn structure see like there's so
many weaknesses for whites chewing
exploit now the tactics that you would
have to consider for Queen c5 are first
of all yeah but there's a bit of a for
yeah it's intermediate you can't take
back you have to go play King your Swan
now let's say Queen c5 and night c5 and
something maybe now the ninth is
attacking both d4 pawn and h4 pawn which
one do you want to try to keep as black
which one can you keep
hopefully well no I just took on c5
yeah I mean it's I feel like this guy is
falling regardless of what you do
because if you play something like
Bishop III even
there's dirt lot of different tactics
there could be an IP 7 and the night
coming to d6 like 97 and maybe 96 q1
it's your 19 d6 few moves ago right yeah
there is like a lot of difference White
has many many different pretty awesome
ideas and even yeah even though like
right now on the board White has one
less pawn white still holds the
advantage and so the way they went about
it in the game is with Bishop c2 so
you're just kind of I feel like wanted
to prevent okay hold on here if it was
white to move again there is this idea
of 91 that would attack both pieces both
bishops like a shish kebab
yeah
well this Bishop c2 because because if
you play like night h4 could be
something like a bishop c2 Knight d4
could be something Leoben but maybe
Bishop e3 there's all you just want to
not give your opponent any chance and if
it was white to move again night e1
should be winning a piece I think yeah
so black has to get rid of that idea
somehow so black hands just play
something chilled like moving the king
or something so that's why Bishop seats
you should be at least one of your
candidates and Brooke takes d4 and now
you exchange stuff off Bishop e5 doesn't
work because c2 is under attack
so both of your Knights are under attack
both ups are your bishops are in the
attack one with Knight one with jerk how
can you not lose a piece as black
okay
not losing move
yep good job yes Bishop III is the only
not closing move to put it 96 is a very
natural move but I feel like you have to
think which Knight you want to put to e6
because if you play like Knight d2 e6
there could be some potential tax and
then you have to move the knight where
do you go
it's would give your opponent's chances
of trying to trick you and then you
would have to it would just create
unnecessary gain for your opponent
whereas if you play this Knight to e6
you're still attacking this bishop and
so blacks next move should be with this
bishop and the only place that if it was
if you go somewhere like F or even
though it might look pretty cool there
is recap sevens so the only place to
actually go which makes sense is g6 to
protect this square but now
yeah but even after that something like
rook f3 attacks to your other Bishop you
have to move it away back because
something like Bishop c1 there could
also be no and Knight f5 and now I want
to try and go to f7 or come and try to
hunt down your pawn so here after rook
f3 in the game they play Bishop h6 I
feel like it makes sense
but if anybody has where do you think
your Bishop should go do you want to
exchange it off to denied it immediately
do you want to try to go to D 2 c1
I feel like Bishop h6 is kind of logical
but I don't think there's much
difference between Bishop c1 or Bishop
h6 regardless of the white plan so
Bishop h6 could simply want to just
cover up more squares sorry yeah because
I mean if you go Bishop C one maybe
whites would even try to do something
like manage night FA it's like this
might not even work
but mr. h6 at least takes away I crazy
ideas
so after neither v makes sense because
your nights are kind of it's a very good
position but you can't really improve
your position any more than this so you
have to make a change and you have white
has a slight advantage but the problem
is like converting advantages is a very
big deal to understand for someone who's
trying to cross a certain level so right
now you have a good position and
everybody can see that everybody
understands that white has a better
position but not everybody can try and
understand not everybody could actually
follow it true and make decisions that
are necessary to convert a simple
advantage to a more advantage and
possibly win so that's converting your
advantage to a win is very very hard
thing to do I'm still working on mine
but yeah so Knight f5 is something that
you might be hesitant to do I think for
me my it for myself it would take I
would have to kind of like talk myself
in into it like through it like so what
am i doing is this like I would
definitely have it as a candidate move
but I don't know if I would actually
have the guts to go through with it
because when I you play Knight f5 even
though it looks like you still have a
good
but your night is not protected anymore
and II like how how are you going to try
and push the punt are you going to try
and push the pond they're like yeah you
I wouldn't have an answer for those
questions in a short period of time I
would actually have to sit down and
think about it but yeah if 95 is what
the position needs what's what the
position needs so in this situation they
started to convert the advantage even
further and they entered a rock end game
and in broken game King activity is
super important so it's a who's king can
get to Center first pretty much
attacking the palm so you can't play
King u5 as easily because if King you're
5 take and take a 7 and everything goes
WAPA so you kind of like have to play
rookie 7 to protect h7 now you want to
play king of five if rook is five you
take a five King f3 King a 5 now you
take on h4 and in this position and it's
kind of blundered a little bit because
it's so one of those things that I was
just talking about converting advantages
you might not see in first glance that
this endgame the pawn endgame is
actually losing it actually takes a lot
of knowledge and a lot of a very high
understanding of chess and endgame to
know for sure that the same game is
winning and white fearlessly had that
because he was pretty confident I
actually went on watch the interview
that he gave after because I was curious
that if he got lucky or he knew what he
was doing
and he said that yeah he was pretty sure
that this was winning the endgame
deponent game was winning and he's 16
and he knows these end games he has that
instincts he has that understanding the
maturity of what the position needs what
so why it is a leaders of fear whose job
yeah
he is also iranian-born recently moved
to France
yeah yes yes hopefully I'll have a
little bit of time to go over letters a
father thinks I'm not sure I don't want
to be a politician but chess and
politics is always fun yeah that's not
really people involved in those but for
the people watching it is pretty
interesting yeah so mmm like all right
back to Chester a little bit longer here
something like a five would be the way
to go for black because we're gonna see
more in the opponent's game ya5 is was
necessary but you see the problem is if
okay if you keep playing a 5 there is
root fe4 if you would play rook e5 your
H 5 minus h7 pine is hanging also there
could be rook h5 and taking the rook
back so this pawn this pawn is like a
little bit poisonous but at the same
time what how can white make progress
white can to start pushing on g4 because
if g4 now King e5 well it can't move the
King because of rookie 5 so it's more
like white is also a little bit of stuck
even though white has one more pawn in
the endgame this pawn is yeah I'm gonna
call it poisonous because you can't take
it as black and as White's you can't
really your hands are a bit tight
because you can you don't know how to
proceed
yeah well these are yeah well the other
thing is like when you go to the end
game for at least pond and games
those little tempies are very important
so I feel like if black spawn were
advanced enough well I could have still
a good fighting chance so maybe that's
why a 5 would be a good idea because
even if this Raqqah 4 is played I mean
to my understanding this is still should
white has a better chance of winning I
don't know for a fact if this is winning
or not but it seems that it should be
but at least black is trying to put up a
good fight to start pushing more pawns
so I feel like that was necessary at all
another thing is your your opponent
wants to do this exchange as black white
the way to think about it as black is
your opponent's wants you to take on e5
so what your opponent is going to try
and provoke you to take on e5 to invite
you provoke you something so why would
you willingly do it
put some itch a5 and make it a little
bit harder or make something out of it I
do teach a chess on psychology so that's
being it's been pretty fun to try and
talk about the psychological aspects of
chess and so yeah
long story short Geary took on e5 ended
up with a check here
gotta move the king exchange and now we
have a very interesting King King and
King pawns and King gains pawns
so the way that both players went about
it so fear is replete king f4 which
doesn't seem like the most accurate move
because King d6 would be a good
resistance mmm but well in the game they
played King f6 Ivo go more in depth in
this specific endgame later on in the
endgame that's coming up Tuesday yeah
because I feel like it's such an
important endgame and I don't want to
just wing it so I'm like maybe preparing
more for that but King and pawns are
very tricky and games it takes you have
to calculate you cannot just wing it
and
it's about time for white to start
pushing his majority G for now black has
to also try and create something
otherwise this is totally lost
you can't really play b5 because I mean
b5 is going to happen sooner rather than
later but the problem is as soon as you
give this b5 we these pawns are faster
you cannot really take it and oops and
as we see in the game in the game the
way they players went about it is with
h6h for trying to create a clear path
pound take take oops
which King it's more important to have
the past pawn far far away from the king
rather than towards the center because
the King has to go try to stop it and
now white king will come and take care
of these guys and it's important not to
give chances like this because it might
work it might not work but it's better
not to risk it so it's important to
calculate em King e5 take 9 you have
king d4 a3 doesn't work and you can come
up and take these pawns with clear mind
and then take all the pawns rather than
having to stress over if b5 take take a
4 before a3 works
yeah after kingi five of the game
actually ended and white one yeah this
was we are black resigned this was
actually this was a very interesting
game why didn't really do anything crazy
just made I want to say like more
accurate moves
I'd rather than blacked it and got out
of the opening better but like so again
I don't really know fear is just
personality I remember him as a kid this
yeah hi
now he's I from yeah and yeah it's I as
you all know I also switched my
filtration from Iran to feed a and then
to us so I changed to feed it I was on
their feet up flat yeah for a few weeks
yes yeah so I mean I'm sure I mean when
I was going through it
it wasn't really fun for me but it was
very interesting for everybody else to
follow Oh questions for me it was after
the Iranian Federation declared ban
against me or something like that that's
I wasn't I already buy coat the
Federation and I wasn't playing for them
yeah and so like it's like you would
need to have like a good reason that you
don't want your Federation anymore and
you don't even because officially like
by regulations if you want to switch to
a new Federation there's some money
being exchanged between you like the new
Federation old Federation more like sign
of respect and when you go to feed a
flag you
you waive that money completely so your
old Federation won't get a cent for your
switch to wherever else you want to go
and usually players rarely do it because
they feel a bonds and like they feel
like they owe their Federation but I
didn't and well seems like it well it's
more like if your Federation does enough
to help you grow and it's supportive and
you see a future with that Federation
you keep it going but if you don't see a
future and they're more like a barrier
rather than like a stepping stone yeah
she didn't go on their feet if like he
moved from Italy to us and I believe
that they take it it is better if you
have some sort of residency you need
some sort of residency rather than a
visa but it could be a temporary
residency one-year residency mmm yeah
Dominguez yeah he also from what I know
he lives in st. Louis he might I don't
know about how much he travels to here
but he is a residents of us maybe not
permanent but at least for the time
being he has a permanent he has a
residency yeah
yeah it's not very ideally you want to
be in a country and a federation that
you're appreciated you don't really have
to go through the whole hassles of
finding a federation switching to its
being accepted there all of those fun
stuff but when when you can't grow in a
country anymore
you move yeah it's I'm not a very
politic person I don't really I've
recently learned what does being left
and right mean so yeah it's I believe in
freedom of choice you can't grow in some
country and they're not really helping
you they're not understanding your words
they're not trying to keep you pack your
bags go to where they help you
yeah well the cuts are pretty
interesting any more question yeah I'm
glad we hit some interesting topics to
be continued we will go over this
endgame in our Tuesday class in game one
coming up this is there's been a lot of
interesting game games but this is
something that really deserves to go
more in depth so we'll do that hopefully
it will also be streamed so if you can't
attend you can find it on youtube yeah
well this was fun thank you you're
smiling
[Music]
you
you